the biggest disappointment to me with
modern horror is that nobody's using it
in as allegory and at all I mean it's
you know that's what it's there for
nursery rhymes are political and
nobody's nobody's doing that it's just
you know hey I got this guy would a
knife and we could make nine movies
about this guy my manager printed up
t-shirts calling me the Godfather of the
dead when I made the first film I never
called him zombies I called him flesh
eaters to me zombies were always those
boys in the Caribbean you know doing the
wet work for Lugosi then in the second
film I called him zombies and I did a
little nod to the Voodoo took some of
the sort of mysterioso voodoo stuff out
of it and made them the neighbors and
the neighbors are frightening enough
when they're alive I just wanted some
sort of a sort of game-changing
disastrous thing to happen that my human
characters could ignore Night of the
Living Dead is the only time that I was
consciously said to myself a few times
during the making of the film that this
is a spooky moment I'm gonna try to
scare you with this the one of the Dead
was a complete comic book I mean I grew
up on easy comic books before the comics
code and you sort of chuckled while you
barf night of living dead first played
in drive-ins from neighborhood theaters
and it actually returned money to us we
actually made money when we made the
first film I never thought would turn
into six films I thought I was just
gonna do this little sort of angries
kind of 60s thing about disintegration
of the family you know the the lack of
civility and aside from you know a few
lingering angry voices like Roger Ebert
saying you know look what these evil
people will do if you know we need a
controlling group like the MPAA and it
went away and then all of a sudden
Cahiers du cinéma and there was the
French who really discovered it and
started to write about it as though it
was you know essential American cinema
I do consider myself and on tour to the
extent that I've never taken a job I've
never made a film just for the Paycheck
or for any other reason except it's
something that interests me something I
want to do and I like to have as much
control over it as possible and this
this attitude has cost me a lot of gigs
so I think that's where that reputation
comes from I also do insist that there's
a theme the biggest statement that I
think that I'm making I mean the sky can
be falling and people are still worried
about you know you know I got I got to
pick up my shirts at the cleaners I got
to get on
I got a you know buy a new pair of Nikes
or you know people are just so self
centered and self focused to me that's
the most stunning thing the thing that's
keeping us from you know making real
sort of social civilized progress is the
factional ization that that comes in so
many different ways but that's been true
from the first film the film on they
wind up arguing about should we go in
the basement or stay up here what's
safer
instead of saying guys look what's
happening last time anyone counted 53
million people were dying every year
150,000 everyday 107 every minute they
become an us-versus-them world
all we were looking for was a place
where there was no them diary costs a
little to make that that despite limited
release it made a lot of money so I said
why don't we sort of strategize this a
little bit so I said I could do three
story lines which will basically in the
end wind up being one piece but three
separate storylines that will interweave
characters will cross plots will cross
and all that and and they will it'll all
come from diary they'll all be
characters that were in diary and then
they will go on and we'll have this
little collage I told the zombies down
in this film they seem to be less of a
threat they're almost like you know an
annoyance so a lot of mosquitoes out
tonight I did that purposely because I
wanted to just really try to bring that
focus now to use stupid idiots I mean
you're still shooting at each other
you're even arguing over what to do with
the zombies wish I had the magic bullet
that couldn't make people to say God you
know but no one is ever gonna say you
know what you're right I'm an
you